We are welcoming back to the program today,
Congressman Rokaya representing California's
17th district, located in the heart of Silicon
Valley.
Always great to have you on.
It's always a pleasure.
So what what's your big picture take away
of the November election?
Joe Biden won.
The Senate is still a question mark.
It appears as though Democrats lost a few
seats in the House, but will still will still
maintain an advantage.
You could I mean, I can psych myself into
thinking the results are great because it's
so difficult to remove an incumbent president
and we should be glad that we at least did
that and so on.
And at the same time, absolutely, historically,
terrible reaction to coronavirus should have
been an overwhelming, humiliating defeat for
Donald Trump.
And it was really pretty close in a few states.
I don't know which side is the right side.
Well, that's probably truth to both.
Obviously, it's very hard to defeat an incumbent,
but Biden managed with all of the help of
everyone to flip five states.
That's the most important task.
But there are certain warning lessons in there.
One, I don't think we had a strong enough
economic message that came through.
Exit polling showed that of people who prioritize
the economy, 80 some percent voted for Trump
over us.
Now, I've seen some statistics which say that
people who made over one hundred thousand
voted for Trump and those who made under one
hundred thousand voted for us.
But that if you break that down further, you
see that we do very, very well with those
making under one hundred thousand who are
black or Latino.
We do not do very well with those who are
making hundred thousand who are white and
rural communities and communities left out.
And so the challenge for the party is still
how do we have an economic message or a aspirational
message that reaches a lot of these communities?
Because until we have House seats and all
of these districts and an Electoral College,
you're not going to get progressive change
on Medicare for all and free public college
and student debt forgiveness very hard if
you don't win some of these areas.
Is a second Korona coronavirus stimulus bill
something that should be?
I mean, it obviously takes more than a day,
but something that Joe Biden has to start
on on day one.
Yes, I mean, I'm hopeful that we can do something
now before we adjourn.
The the idea I mean, look at here's what I
think.
McConnell thinks he thinks the economy will
eventually recover and there's sort of an
indifference to the suffering.
But there is this suffering that is going
on.
I mean, people are being kicked out of their
houses, of their apartments.
Their don't have, in many cases, enough food
to eat.
And this has already gone on too long.
As you remember, I was urging that we come
to some deal before the election.
That would have been one point eight, one
point nine trillion.
I don't think that offer is even going to
be in the on the table anymore.
But we've got to do something.
And certainly if we don't have something done
by the time Biden comes, that has to be his
top priority.
You mentioned what you think Mitch McConnell
is thinking.
Have any of your Republican colleagues who
are seeing this voter fraud narrative with
bogus lawsuits, melting lawyers and all of
these different strange things that we're
seeing?
Have any of them leveled with you and said,
listen, publicly I'm supporting it, but I
don't believe it and here's why I want to
stay in Trump's good graces or like, do you
have any insight into what they're thinking
now?
You know, the interesting thing is that I
have relationships with a number of the Republicans
that Trump is on top of my bills.
We work on Yemen, but they will not, even
in private, criticize Trump.
There's such a fear that that could get out
that someone could say something, that it
could get back to Trump.
So I have never had a Republican colleague,
even in private, in the House side at least
say, oh, you know what, we need to move on
the very, very careful, very careful what
they put in tax.
Very careful what they would say to a to a
colleague when the when the topic is Donald
Trump.
So in terms of the Joe Biden cabinet, we're
learning about more and more of the picks.
Maybe one of the more controversial ones is
Neera Tanden for OMB.
We're going to talk about that tomorrow.
We've seen Janet Yellen for Treasury, which
I think is actually very interesting.
And she has some really interesting economic
literature and history that she's participated
in over the last 30 years, which has been
interesting to look at the general idea of
Bernie Sanders, Elizabeth Warren leaving the
Senate to be part of the Cabinet.
Aside from specific positions strategically,
do you like it or not like it?
I think they should be part of the government.
At least one of them should be just because,
you know, we forget that Bernie Sanders won
the first three states.
I mean, I know you got the most delegates,
but he got the most votes in Iowa, New Hampshire,
Nevada.
He got millions of votes.
And so to have that wing of the party not
represented, I think is a mistake.
It's a mistake for Joe Biden.
It's a mistake in terms of the progressive
energy.
So Department of Labor is actually a place
he would make a big difference.
I would support that.
And it'll be a challenge if they both are
shut out.
And my understanding is the Vermont governor
is committed to appointing an independent.
It would caucus with Democrats.
I also think Bernie Sanders has earned this.
I mean, if he wants to continue to represent
folks in the Senate, that's his prerogative.
But if he feels like he wants to make an impact
in the Labor Department, I don't see how with
his success and all he represents, why this
is even a fight for him to get this position.
So if the position of the Biden transition
team were simply we can't afford to lose them
in the Senate, that would not satisfy you
as an explanation?
No, because Bernie Sanders wouldn't give up
the Senate.
And he has clearly gotten a commitment from
the Republican governor that they will appoint
an independent there who will caucus with
the Democrats.
So if if they were going to be blunt and said
we don't want Bernie Sanders for X, Y and
Z reason, I think that would be more honest.
My view is that it would be a mistake not
to give Bernie Sanders a platform where he
thinks he can be most impactful.
Bernie Sanders thinks he can do that in the
Department of Labor is he's earned that opportunity.
Speaking of leaving the Senate, I mean, of
course, we have to mention that in your state,
Kamala Harris is going to be the vice president
of the United States.
And so that will be a seat that opens.
I've read a little bit about who the sort
of front runners are.
Your name is being mentioned by many progressives
as someone they would like to see Draft Rokan,
call Gavin Newsom and say, is that is that
a position that would be interesting to you
or anyone would be honored to to represent
the state in the Senate?
And it would give me probably a bigger platform
to have an impact on progressive policies.
But I believe I can also be very effective
from the House.
And, you know, the leading candidate appears
to be Padia.
My bigger issue is can we get someone?
Is progressive, it was clearly for Medicare
for all, it was clearly for a 15 hour minimum
wage, free public college or vocational education,
forgiving student loans.
And how do we a policy and there are a number
of people who would fit that bill.
But that, to me is the most important.
Yeah.
What's interesting, I like that you bring
that up because I wanted to talk about what
is the strategy even with a 50 50 Senate with
Kamala Harris has a tiebreaker vote.
There are lots of Democrats in the Senate
who are not on board with a lot of the ideas
you just talked about.
And so there's actually a real question.
I mean, things like Medicare for all and and
many other ideas like Joe Manchin is not a
guaranteed vote on a lot of those things.
And we could go sort of down the list of some
of the more centrist, right leaning Democratic
senators.
Is that a concern to you?
And thinking about the best case scenario
right now would be 50 50 with Kamala Harris
is the tie breaker.
It seems to me that even in that scenario,
there are real challenges in getting some
of some of the things we'd like to see done
actually done.
David, you're actually right.
And this is where there is a philosophical
difference of what way the Obama administration
should go.
One theory of the case is let's solve the
debt limit, get the vaccine out, and then
there's going to be some natural recovery
to the economy.
And let's get whatever we can get in either
a Republican Senate or a divided Senate where
everything has to get mansion's vote.
I don't think that's sufficient.
I think the better strategy is to say, here
is our vision.
We've got record income inequality.
We've got people who have been left out.
We need to have massive public investment
in the creation of new jobs.
We need to have massive investment in childcare
and education and health care.
We're going to pass that in the House.
We're going to build public support.
We're going to make that case.
And even if we're losing votes in the Senate,
eventually in twenty two, twenty four, twenty
six and twenty eight, we're going to get that
just society.
Any great leader in this country is not overnight
brought change.
They built public support.
We've seen what Bernie did from 2016 to now.
So to surrender the effort at building public
support because it's hard or the numbers aren't
there, I think is an abdication of political
imagination and political leadership.
Yeah, I mean, speaking, if we apply a pragmatic
filter to that for a moment, we can imagine
a situation where Democrats don't have the
Senate.
And then the big things that Joe Biden campaigned
on, which are an expansion of Obamacare, public
option, et cetera, pretty significant changes
to the tax code, including on capping Social
Security beyond 400 K stepped up basis elimination.
You know, we look at the full list of the
really big stuff.
I'm hearing two things from from different
people on the left.
And we just lost your video.
I don't know.
And you're back.
There you go.
That was right.
So we're hearing two things from people on
the left and right on the left, rather, some
on the left are saying you can't these Republicans
in the Senate cannot be compromised with what
you would need to give up as Joe Biden if
you don't have the Senate to get any of those
things done, would essentially degrade the
quality of the bill where Joe Biden would
be giving huge concessions to the Republican
Party that are simply not worth doing.
The other side is it's worth doing in order
to get anything at all, but it might end up
being sort of a Pyrrhic victory.
Do you have a strong feeling one way or the
other about how far it's worth negotiating
with people who are often negotiating out
of such bad faith?
Well, it depends on the context, I mean, if
it's a matter of getting some unemployment
assistance to people and you know, where we
can get three hundred or four hundred dollars
instead of six hundred dollars, I say we probably
have to compromise to get the relief.
If we're talking about expanding Medicare,
if we're talking about free public college
and if we're talking about student loan forgiveness.
And there's really something, Tolkan, that
the Republicans are agreeing to, but they're
asking for draconian cuts in other programs,
then?
Absolutely not.
What I would say is, let's pass in the House.
Let's pass an advocate in the White House,
at least Biden's policies.
I mean, let's at least make sure that that
they're passing then I don't see any justification
for Joe Biden and Nancy Pelosi not passing
every single thing that he campaigned on.
I mean, isn't that what prompted I mean, did
Trump it was wrong, but obviously went down
this checklist.
Here's what I campaigned on.
Here's what I'm going to try to do.
So Biden ought to do the same thing.
We have a Democratic House.
There's no reason why we shouldn't have every
single thing that he campaigned on up for
a vote.
And if we lose the vote, let people know which
Democrats voted against it, let people know
who voted against the public option, who voted
against Medicare to 60, who voted against
it, uncapping Social Security taxes over raising
having taxes, over four hundred thousand who
voted against raising capital gains taxes,
over a million dollars.
There are a lot of policies that we ought
to vote on.
My fear is that they're going to say, oh,
let's have a lowest common denominator.
Manchin, the moderate Democrats aren't for
it, that we're not going to have a vote and
that's not going to fly, especially given
that we have the House last thing.
Let's talk a little bit about what's going
on with the virus.
We fortunately appear to be just a couple
of weeks from the first vaccine, starting
to the first doses of the first vaccine, starting
to get to people December eight to 10.
There's going to be this meeting to look at
least at the Pfizer emergency use authorization
shortly thereafter.
The Moderna one, we're told, within 24 to
48 hours of that, which could be December
11th, 12th, 13th, the first doses are going
to start going into people's arms.
There's two things that are sort of going
on here.
One is the initially limited supply of these
vaccines where you can hopefully, best case,
inoculate 20 million people a month.
That's going to take a while before we get
to to to some level of herd immunity.
The other side is 40 percent of the country
still says they're not really interested in
getting a vaccine, which will make it very
difficult to ever get to that herd immunity.
What are you and your colleagues looking at
and thinking about in terms of the vaccination
program?
Yeah, there was an interesting idea, actually,
by John Delaney, who sent it to the op ed
to me, that he says that we ought to be linking
a fifteen hundred dollar stimulus or payment
to getting the vaccine.
Now, I haven't looked at all the constitutionality
or ethics around it, but I think having some
sort of incentive system to get vaccine adoption
should be on the table.
But at the very least, we need massive funding
on on outreach and figuring out how we incentivize
hospitals to get the get it distributed.
But I think it is it's going to be a challenge.
I mean, you've got to get to about 60, 70
percent vaccination.
And that's going to be the administrative
challenge.
I will say this about Ron Klain.
He's exceedingly competent.
And whatever else you think about the Biden
administration, I do think he will manage
this process.
Well, yeah.
I mean, the crazy thing is initially none
of these vaccines will be given to children.
And once you remove children from the three
hundred and thirty million population, you
actually need close to 100 percent of adults
to get to that 70 percent.
And I don't think that that that is necessarily
being taken taken seriously.
You're saying I haven't even thought about
that point.
And it's a good point.
I mean, look, this is where I think that the
Obama administration is.
I mean, they're going to be judged in the
first six months to nine months on the administrative
rollout of this vaccine.
And I'm sure in the back of their minds is
that when the Affordable Care Act happened,
it was botched the rollout, and that really
hurt people and it hurt the public perception.
So they're right to be focused on that administration.
But there is a dual crisis.
There's that problem and then there's an economic
crisis.
And then there's a structural crisis that
Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders spoke
about, in my view, is we can't ignore both
the structural crisis and the immediate crisis
economically, and we have to pay attention
to that substantively and for political reasons.
Do you like the idea of airlines, concert
venues, et cetera, saying after a certain
date, if you want to come to an event or fly
with us, you must be vaccinated?
Yes, I think that that's a very reasonable
position.
And and and probably constitutional.
I mean, my sense is that you are required
to have vaccinations to go to school, for
example.
So the conditioning being in public places,
it makes sense.
You know, I was talking to a because I represent
Silicon Valley, one of the privileges I get
to talk to some of these leading technologists
and scientists and talking to someone yesterday
who said that if we put the resources, there's
no reason we couldn't have vaccine detectors
like smoke detectors, which could literally
detect almost any vaccine in a room.
And we put so much money in our military so
that we could detect the smallest threat to
our country militarily.
I don't understand why we're not putting in
the resources now to be detecting pandemics
and future pandemics.
That is interesting.
That is not one I had heard, but I will certainly
look into that.
We've been speaking with Congressman Roe,
representing California's 17th District.
Always a pleasure having you on.
David, thank you for having me on your show.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.